[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we were fortunate to have rick stroud on
the
buccaneers beat rider for the tampa bay
times throughout the season
we started before the season started
when brady's uh
signed there and rick has been with us
throughout the season kind of the highs
and lows and
i don't know where he was when that
team's seven and five and i wondered if
they were going to make the playoffs
and here we are is super bowl champs
rick joins us now
rick what were you expecting to happen
last night
um you know i got to be the pool
reporter and we're not allowed to say
anything about that
what we see but look this was a
confident football team
and i dan i heard you say it during the
week they had an entirely
beat up offensive line i didn't know how
the kansas city chiefs were going to
stop that front four and i knew that
todd both was going to rush
for he was going to drop seven right and
that math is in his favor because they
only got five eligible there to keep the
safeties deep
you didn't know what patrick mahomes was
going to do and after a while
it kind of looked like a texas tech
spring game you know where he's just
running around out there trying to find
anybody over
well and explain by as the pool reporter
like what access did you have uh
that other reporters didn't have well i
was
i mean they assigned one uh for each
team and i was the only guy that got to
go
or the only reporter got to go and watch
practice we got to watch the whole
practice
um and it wasn't anything different than
normally during the year i mean we don't
get to see that much
but this this was a confident football
team i mean look if you talk to those
guys on defense they're like wait a
minute
we went into new orleans and yeah
everybody was talking about drew brees
after the game but
they had our number and we beat those
guys down then we went to green bay and
took down the most valuable player in
the nfl
and when they're sitting around they're
getting a bunch of young guys on defense
sitting around on social media and
watching television and
listening to shows like yours and
they're hearing everybody come on and
say that kansas city is going to hang 37
on them and they just
they couldn't believe that they felt you
know it's it's bulletin board right it
seems
simplistic but they really did feel like
nobody was giving them
what they had earned what they had done
on the field even in the postseason
go back to november what kind of doubts
do you think
i mean you lost to the saints what was
that 38.3 got blown out there
what what kind of doubts do you think
tampa had about themselves
well i mean if you talk to them uh you
know they
stayed together and that's a hard thing
to do when you're in that position i
think
tom brady said it today you know with
this pandemic
they really couldn't get to hang out and
know each other very well this is a
close knit team that did it
um you know without being able to go to
dinner or all those extra things
but it was sort of a uh like if you're a
football junkie
you got into it and that's what they did
they just went to work i think that you
know
uh bruce arians got together with byron
left which it really started coming
together the end of the second half the
kansas city game the fire week
really was big for him so they never
really got down and in fact
um before this game i mean tom brady
texted
everybody on the team and said simply we
will win
i mean before this game and and that
that's a powerful
message i mean i'm covering this guy
it's like he's the gridiron gandhi
like i i don't even know like when
you're when you're watching it it's just
amazing the impact that he has
on so many players and so many guys in
the uh in the administration
yeah i think that that's you know an
understated aspect to brady that
if i'm a younger player i look at him
and i know that anything's possible
that he came back from 28 to 3 in the
super bowl
that confidence level can't be
understated but i'm wondering
who was the mvp in your opinion
well i mean if you could give it to a
whole defense or you could give it to
todd bowles you would because if i had a
vote and i
and not that i feel bad voting for brady
i mean he's won
five of these um the numbers weren't
very impressive other than the three
touchdowns
but it was hard to pick one guy i think
shaq barrett had a big game i think uh
you know devon white certainly did it's
just that nobody stood out
so much above the others i mean you can
even make a case for
rob gronkowski you had a good game but i
think the defense was the story of this
game no question about it you keep a
team like that
from scoring a touchdown i mean that's
just remarkable
yeah and you're trying to like what what
are the odds that you're going to get
gronk antonio brown and leonard
fournette
to all have big performances in the
super bowl if you would have said
one is going to have a big performance i
would have said okay
i never would have thought all three
would yeah i didn't
i didn't see that i mean gronk has has
kind of been mostly a blocker of late
um you know but that's another thing too
and this is about trust not that he
didn't trust the other guys he did
i think the ball just kind of went that
way with the defense but look at who he
went to in big moments
rob gronkowski right um you know
antonio brown uh even leonard fournette
none of those guys were on this roster
when tom brady got here
and that's not an accident i mean those
guys came here because of tom brady
every one of them
um were somebody that he lobbied for and
that he felt could help their football
team and they all did in a big way in
super bowl
so brady's coming back aryans is coming
back gronk says he's coming back
i'm assuming antonio brown is going to
want to come back
but there's a you're going to lose a
couple of players or the potential for
losing a couple of players what's the
offseason going to look like for the
buccaneers
well they're going to have to hope that
some guys want to win more than they
want to earn some money because they
just don't have enough for all of them i
i think that you know you look at shaq
barrett who they franchise
um they need to do a long-term deal with
him if not if you use a franchise tag on
him what about chris scott when you
don't want to lose that receiver
um you know they've got some tough
decisions to make it won't be the same
football team it never is that's why
teams can't repeat we haven't seen it
since 10405 or whatever the patriots did
um but you know there will be other guys
around the nfl that see what happened
here in tampa
uh and at various points of their career
much like fernette was and want to come
down
and uh and be with a team that could win
a super bowl and so
i think brady's impact will have a lot
to do with how they're able to keep this
team together and whether
even guys like indomicon sue want to
keep playing or not
you know i go back and there there were
some strange moments the entire year
remember when the the high school
practices and surveillance cameras and
tom's trying to get guys together
surreptitiously
hey man i was the one that found that
practice okay it took me a lot of people
were you hiding in the bushes rick were
you hiding in the box
that is urban myth that did not happen
uh i was actually like
you told me it did you said you were
hiding in the bushes
it wasn't hiding it was on a public
street i was kind of peering over
okay um i just had to get above it okay
yeah we found it
uh oh well it's been a long run i told
people if you are of a certain age
then you know what the buccaneers have
been aside from the super bowl win
they've been the laughing stock of the
nfl for a long long long time
and uh you're gonna i hope these fans
appreciate this for a long time i mean
they may think you're coming back again
next year
but i hope they appreciate this one for
a long time and they should
well dan i walked out onto the field
afterwards and confetti was still there
and i looked up and all and no one had
left and then i realized they were
cardboard cutouts that it was actually
just the
the people that were still there but uh
you know
it's tampa bay now i mean it's
incredible what has happened this year
with the lightning winning the stanley
cup and raising the world series and all
of that
um but i think yeah for the fans this is
great i mean 12 years without
playoffs 18 years without winning a
playoff game
you get tom brady and you win the super
bowl i mean this is really
maybe we can have nice things maybe
maybe tampa bay can't have next thing
and we almost got sued by tom brady for
uh tampa bay t-shirts that we put out
yeah well you know we got a cease and
desist or
i think we were threatened with a season
desist
uh with tom's uh law firm have you seen
the seven clothing line now
the seven that's that's the next that's
the big thing don't put it don't put a
seven
on anything he the number seven
apparently the whole number
it's like sesame street you know that
that's brady's number now is seven
i'm gonna go eight i'm gonna go ahead to
eight so i can bypass the seven and not
worry about tom
hey thank you thank you very much for uh
all your uh
contributions there this year and your
sense of humor we appreciate it rick
hey dan thanks for having me it's been a
pleasure man that's rick stroud he
covers the buccaneers for the tampa bay
times